what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch from new rock stars their shang
chi ending explained post credit scene
breakdown because yes we did see shang
chi and do we know what's really going
on not really so it would be very
helpful to get one of the master
theorist opinions on what's happening
here and i'm sure he'll have much better
insight than both of our minds combined
obviously spoilers in here if you
haven't seen chongqi yet but hey let's
see what's going on
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and chongqi in the legend of the 10
rings change the game of the mcu in ways
that'll knock you sideways like
abomination versus wong spoiler warning
before we continue because i'm gonna
break down this movie's finale and post
credit scenes go watch this movie and
i'll be here to help you unpack what the
f just happened okay shanxi has two
post-credits scenes but first a quick
recap chongqi after 10 years of being
separated from his crime lord father
when wu is dragged back into the tin
rings compound alongside his sister xiao
ling when wu uses his children to find
the hidden kingdom of tallow guided by
what he thinks is the voice of his
deceased wife zhang li to rescue her
soul from a sealed cave but when wu is
actually being manipulated by an
otherworldly soul sucker beast who in
the past had been fended off by a dragon
known as the great protector when wu
unwittingly opens the seal to unleash
the mega soul sucker into the realm the
shang chi reclaims the rings from his
father and with the help of the great
protector the warriors of ta lo combined
with those of the ten rings in katy's
archery shanxi slays the monster and all
this is recap too shang chi and katie's
skeptical friends over drinks but then
my favorite party crashing visual effect
in the mcu a portal opens and then comes
wong whom we saw earlier facing
abomination in a friendly cage fight in
macau i gotta say that's a great recap
of the whole movie right there yeah just
looking over the visuals again i mean
that dragon fight at the end is
something magical to behold and then
looking at the other casted characters
too just reminds me like just how solid
this cast is we're going to be doing a
spoiler talk live stream on monday
giving enough time for everyone to watch
this movie who can see it this weekend i
know some spots in the world they can't
see it yet i mean just looking over all
that i'm like damn i'm excited to watch
this movie again yeah yeah
this is so cool now it isn't clear but
abomination might be getting weekend
passes after he was detained following
his battle with hulk and harlem or maybe
abomination is wong's sparring partner
whom he doesn't mention bruce banner
because the first rule of warnings fight
club is you don't talk about hanging out
with your friend's enemy anyway one
brings shangchi and katie to the sanctum
sanctorum since they have a lot to talk
about and that brings us to our first of
two post-credits
wong uses his magic to analyze the ten
rings alongside shanghi and katie while
on a conference call with captain marvel
carol danvers and bruce banner they're
on one of those hollow projection group
chats similar to the way the avengers
checked in with each other and end game
banner looks noticeably older and he's
back in human form from his seemingly
permanent smart hulk for him from
endgame but his arm remains in a sling
so the injury he sustained from snapping
the start gauntlet which left him in a
sling in in-game's final minutes is
still a badass remember the ancient one
was able to push banner's human soul out
of his hulk body so maybe banner's
return to human form was some kind of
magic offered by the sorcerers wong and
doctor strange something we could learn
more about in she-hulk along with by the
way whatever wong's friendship with
abomination is all about or maybe
something we could learn more about in
spider-man no way home since doctor
strange seems in a weird mood to grant
his avenger buddies random favors that
is interesting because it seems like
banners back in his uh form like it's
human form but yet abomination stays in
the abomination form i thought at one
point we would see emil blonsky you know
tim roth just had his human form but he
never did switch back which i thought
was a little bit of a weird note that's
the punishment for him is you got to
spend the rest of your life as
abomination they're trying to figure
something out because abomination seemed
like really just like disheartened and
uh tim roth did come back to do some
voice work for him so i don't see why
they couldn't have gotten tim roth at
all to be in here but who knows who
knows danvers confirms that the tech
isn't chitari or any alien tech she has
seen chatari of course being the
warriors of thanos army led by loki in
the first avengers movie tech that was
later repurposed by vultures crew and
spider-man homecoming banner says the
rings aren't made of vibranium the metal
of all of black panther's tech and what
captain america's shield is made out of
and that these rings are way older than
a thousand years old now in the comics
the ten rings are ancient alien macleon
tech that crashed to earth in a
spacecraft and it was from this wreckage
that the mandarin zhengju the character
when wu is based on stole them but in
the film it said that when wu might have
found these rings in a crater or a tomb
but it is not confirmed in comics each
ring contains the soul of a cosmic
warrior and each has different abilities
abilities that are not shown in the film
all 10 rings seem to give off the same
powers of strength enhancement and being
slung as powerful projectiles but these
more mystical qualities are explored
here because wong zooms in to show a
pulsing beacon summoning something from
afar something threatening to change the
mcu as we know it there's no going back
so the question now is who or what are
these 10 rings summoning if the mcu
maintains their mcluhan origins that
threat could be from another planet or
from another galaxy and if we're looking
for ancient beings from the stars
galactus could be on his way okay okay
you could also say the celestials are
coming because we know they're being
summoned back to earth for some
emergence in eternals but i suspect that
that movie might take place in the seven
days after end game which might set it
before shang chi especially since that
movie's release date was supposed to be
before shanghai originally but i cannot
give her answers on the timeline yet but
i will say based on the way this movie
explored
its magic and its relationship to other
realms i think this threat is more
likely to come from another dimension in
the comics talo is one of the god realms
a small pocket dimension adjacent to
earth in the film it's also the nexus
gateway to an additional realm of these
soul suckers with lovecraftian design
elements notably cthulhu or nyarlathote
who telepathically invades mortals minds
much like this beast does to win woo you
could see it similar to how thor said in
avengers that fury's work with the
tesseract signal to all the realms that
earth is ready for a higher form of war
and this beacon could be summoning
whatever inter-dimensional threat that
doctor strange and wong will face in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness how come now though it's
summoning it because it hadn't when wu
had the rings for such a long time like
centuries it sort of seemed like he
stretched out his life and yet now with
sacrament like did it have something to
do with wen wu's connection or to the
ten rings yeah is it because shanghi
takes them over and that's the key to
the transmission or something is it have
to be like a chosen one pure of heart
i love how it's like in the title legend
of the ten rings yet we never really
learn where they come from yeah this
whole time yeah yeah they get you so
focused on that actual narrative at hand
you don't even realize the post credits
like oh yeah we never actually learn
what these are or where they're really
from they've just been some mystical
power they've been wielding over its
immediacy but not really knowing why
they are what they are it's fascinating
stuff we've speculated schuma gorath or
one of the elder gods the fact that the
same interdimensional tentacle monster
just made a second appearance in this
week's episode of what if after the
pilot makes a pretty strong case that
one of these many angled ones could be
the threat on the horizon along with
perhaps other devilish mystic entities
we saw hinted in episode four but we
should also consider c'thun the ancient
demonic author of the darkhold and in
the comics the one who first cursed one
of maximoff with her sorcery or figures
like nightmare or
[Music]
because it is interesting that in this
movie this voice promised you quote your
greatest desires implying some kind of
faustian manipulation but maybe a sign
that marvel rather than going the
strictly christian biblical take on this
character as in the comics might instead
reintroduce him as a more
non-denominational evil with forms
specific to all cultures you know what i
love i'm just more fascinated with what
must be going on with voss behind the
scenes because you seem really
disheartened by the crap that he got
with the whole mephisto train with wanda
vision he's right about king and then
now this mephisto conversation come up
with spider-man her way home it's come
up with the doctor strange the what if
and now even with shang chi it's linking
to a lot of mephisto clues and the
argument and case for mephisto has never
been struck
it just keeps going it's just i really
hope it's the long game and so that way
i could just cheer for erik voss the day
this actually happens because no one is
championing it more than him he's
managed to find more ways to include it
than things that sound like mephisto and
perhaps entities like this mega soul
sucker and dormammu in eliath and loki
were all buffer predators kept at bay by
protectors within our reality but now
that these border beasts have been
slayed and the walls have been shaken
even more dangerous predators from
beyond have arrived to exploit the
scarlet witch peter parker and loki's
destabilization of reality in the mcu in
order to feast on that madness the good
news is now shang chi will join that
fight because as carol danvers jets
after an emergency call maybe some
threat she'll have to deal with in the
marvels banner jokes how he never got
danvers number i guess only nick fury
has that pager access and they tell
shangchi welcome to the circus an
informal invitation to the avengers and
shangti katy and wong celebrate by
singing karaoke including hotel
california which was katie's art of
confusion song mentioned earlier in the
movie i really love that post-credits
scene a lot because it feels like a true
scene yeah you know it's not just like
some commercial first it's got an actual
dynamic to it that applies to the movie
while setting stuff up yeah it's like
there's a mystery and tension the
informal invite to chongqi but then
having this like turn around there with
wong celebrating with them which ties
directly into the movie and the humorous
aspects of that hotel california song
and then singing karaoke together just
making bringing it back to even after
all the mystical fantastical experiences
that katie and chongqi have gone through
they're still the human beings that are
relatable at heart you know yeah
absolutely
it's a really well done post-credits
scene uh more than just like little
tease
yeah sets up a lot of questions and a
lot of theories but very very effective
now the second post-credits scene
catches up with zha ling whom katie and
chung-chi believe to be dismantling the
ten rings after the battle but instead
she takes over her father's throne and
expands the tenring's operation at her
sides are razer fist and john john who
ran her macau club
various aides trade paperwork perhaps
planning the epic fighting tournament we
thought we might see in this film you'll
notice among these training warriors are
a new group of female warriors sparring
with the males and street art covering
the walls of the compound and the title
flashes on screen the ten rings will
return you may notice how the framing
and tone here does evoke the
post-credits see into the mandalorian
season two in which boba fett usurped
the throne of jabba the hutt occupied by
bib fortuna setting up boba fett's
upcoming series the book of boba fett
making me wonder if the ten rings could
appear next in a disney in the book
warriors
white vision versus red guardian a melee
of all the loki variants a melee among
all the peter parker
don't get me those are excited man don't
tease me too much man because i'd be way
too excited about that
i would lose my mind yeah that's way too
awesome dude
like just that montage alone got me in
it just like what a cool what a cool
show that would be who would not want to
watch that it doesn't even have a good
story just good fight scene
you can follow me on instagram and on
twitter at eavos follow and subscribe to
new rockstars thanks for watching bye
thank you so much yay of us that
explained a lot and it got me more
excited for the future man holy crap we
probably won't be around tomorrow for uh
the easter egg breakdown unfortunately
going out of town for a little bit it's
my birthday shooting this on my birthday
i feel like we've earned a little bit of
a weekend away for just a tiny bit but
guys thank you so much for being here
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button and hey let's do a
sarah campbell i just want to say thank
you so much for being part of our
patreon page and then you actually
joined us on uh my birthday live stream
and that meant a lot to me even though
you're already supporting us here you
would support the live stream as well so
sarah uh you've been one hell of a
patron to us one hell of a supporter
happy to call you a friend i wish you
watched these movies so that way you
would actually catch these videos
spontaneously instead of waiting for the
link to arrive at the end of every month
regardless uh your support means more
than you know i hope you we get to have
you stick around
permanently forever that no matter what
financial difficulties come your way
if you get robbed house burns down
whatever it may be that you go
priorities
patron eject don't forget those words
ensure your pledge
[Music]
you